welcome back it's the latest and
greatest products for kids and they are
all inside the paris hotel for the abc
kids expo through wednesday rocky is
there live with a look at what's
trending for tots i think she's having a
lot of fun out there rocky how's it
going
hey jillian yeah i guess i'm the mommy
in training here at the expo okay this
is my baby i'll show you what we're
going to do with him later but first i
want to show you one of the most unique
products on the floor here so cool megan
explain your shoe sure this is woolly
bubs and it is a biodegradable baby shoe
so once your little one outgrows it you
can put it in boiling water and it
completely disappears or you can compost
it and it's gone that is so cool and
because you and your husband have two
very interesting careers just really
quick explain that yes so my husband was
at nike for 15 years and i did
environmental consulting and so we just
smashed them together
when we had three kids we said you know
let's try something new alignment you
guys are a match made in heaven so just
explain where can we get your shoes
really quick uh you can get our shoes at
woolybubbs.com willybobs.com thank you
megan i'm going to go over here now
rocking my baby leah we are back with
leah the chairman of the chairperson
excuse me of the board um so we're going
to talk to
we're going to talk about gear right yep
okay tell us what that means gear is
just so important to keep your baby safe
you want to keep that little baby safe
i've been trying to represent kind of
but
let us know who we're going to talk to
over here
kate britex kate debra texas kate at
bridesex okay kate hi okay so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to hand you the
mic kate and i'm going to try and you
know buckle my baby and i'm mommy in
training right so explain your product
will i do that sure so i'm kate i'm with
britax car seats this is the advocate
click tight convertible it has some
awesome technology on it we're going to
show how the child is buckled in so
she's putting him in and i'm going to
actually pull that buckle out front this
is going to be a standing installation
the harness goes up and over the
shoulders buckles in
you can do it oh come on you can do it
there we go there we go and then you
buckle the chest clip the chest clip
goes right there you go right at the
chest level here armpit level it looks
great and you just want to tighten that
up make sure that everything's nice and
snug again this is the advocate click
tight convertible it has an awesome
installation feature you can buy these
on
us.britax.com and all of our retailers
are located on there too i love that and
you were telling me something really
special about this the material is
unique right yes so this material is
very unique it's called safe wash and it
has no added fr chemicals and parents
are looking for no chemicals in car
seats these days so no added chemicals
to the fabrics and it's machine washable
and dryable we need that with the babies
and you know what else i want to show
off look at this for the traveling mom
okay we've got
seat on wheels okay sweet on wheels okay
and where did leah go where did leah go
leah
leah
really quick before we go thank you so
much kate um so before we go just
explain one more time what the expo is
and how people can get in touch with you
and find all these products so this is a
premier juvenile baby show anything to
clothe feed
carry your child is where we are abc
kids expo we'll be back here again at
the paris next year so we're happy to be
here in vegas and again it's not for
parents at home it's for businesses it's
for influencers anyone who is selling
baby products right so all of the
consumers that might be watching your
show they'll go to their local specialty
tour and see all these new goods there
you go there you go for you mommy's in
training we're almost there
all right we'll be right back here on
las vegas